Hi zusammen!
Wir machen heute einen Schokokuchen, der ist so schön glitschig und nass
und der sieht sehr unscheinbar aus wenn er so auf dem Tisch steht
aber das ist einer dieser Schokokuchen, wo jeder denkt:
"Boah, das schmeckt mir! Das weiß ich jetzt schon ganz genau ohne probiert zu haben!"
Ich lege direkt los, das ist ein sehr unkompliziertes Rezept-
[Hamza] Aber nur noch zur Info ganz kurz!
[Kiki] Ja bitte?
[Hamza] Wir haben heute Dienstag, den 15. - Ja, Haselnusscreme als Hintergrundbild! - 20 Uhr.
[Kiki] 20 Uhr!
[Hamza] Und das Video kommt morgen online um 18 Uhr.
Um 18 Uhr!
*mit hoher Stimme* Und dazwischen haben wir noch ungefähr 1000 Dinge zu erledigen aber wir machen das total gerne
[Kiki] ...und deshalb stehen wir hier!
[Hamza] *mit hoher Stimme* Ja! Man merkt auch an deiner Stimme, dass du richtig Spaß hast!
Aber hab ich wirklich weil ich bin ganz ehrlich! Hätt ich keinen Spaß dran, würde ich sagen:
"Hey Leute, das Video morgen fällt aus und.."
[Hamza] Nein!
[Kiki] Nein, machen wir nicht!
Wir legen jetzt direkt los! Also!
Ich benutze meine Küchenmaschine..läuft die zweite Kamera?
[Hamza] Ja!
[Kiki] Sehr gut!
Ihr könnt auch euer Handrührgerät benutzen aber dann führt ihr ungefähr 8min
und ich brauche hier mit der Küchenmaschine ungefähr 4, maximal 5min.
Da gebe ich jetzt Eier rein. Wie immer stehen die ganz genauen Mengenangaben unten in der Videobeschreibung.
Einfach aufklappen und einen Screenshot machen!
Und da gebe ich jetzt auch schon Zucker mit dazu.
Und dann wie gesagt schlage ich das auf maximaler Geschwindigkeit
und danach kommen Öl und Milch hinein.
[Hamza] Und ich hab gar keine Ahnung, was das für ein Kuchen wird!
Ich hab's doch grad erzählt!
[Hamza] Ja ich weiß aber ich kann's mir gar nicht vorstellen!
[Kiki] Okay, dann lass dich überraschen!
So, die flüssigen Zutaten nur ganz kurz unterrühren!
Also wirklich nur 3sek, das reicht schon!
Und jetzt kommen die trockenen Zutaten rein, die bitte unbedingt sieben!
Jetzt könnt ihr die entweder vorab miteinander vermischen oder ihr macht das einfach hier in dem Sieb.
Hier habe ich Mehl, Backkakao und Backpulver.
Und das auch nur ganz kurz unterrühren.
Backofen habe ich auch schon vorgeheizt und der Teig geht wirklich sehr, sehr schnell!
Der Teig ist fertig.
Sehr lecker!
So und jetzt hab ich hier meinen Backrahmen auf meinem Backblech, Backpapier unten drunter gelegt.
Und der Teig ist sehr flüssig und trotz dass mein Backblech sehr gerade ist,
mein Backrahmen auch gerade ist und nicht irgendwie verbogen ist,
ist es ganz normal, dass bei flüssigeren Teigen ein bisschen was rauslaufen kann, also wirklich nur minimal.
Daher mache ich mal Trick 17.
[Hamza] Einschlagen!
Einschlagen, genau!
So, der Schokokuchen wird jetzt im vorgeheizten Backofen bei 180° C Ober- und Unterhitze für ca. 20min gebacken
Und wir machen jetzt diese Schokotränke fertig.
Dafür habe ich mir Milch in meine Pfanne oder meinen Topf gegeben
und da gebe ich jetzt Zucker dazu - aber Herd noch nicht einschalten!
Zucker dazu, Backkakao - der löst sich ein bisschen schwerer auf, da müssen wir gleich ordentlich rühren!
Nicht den Trinkkakao benutzen Leute!
Dann Butter und Vanilleextrakt...ich geb's jetzt mit den Händen rein, oder?
[Hamza] Ja!
[Kiki] Ist doch egal!
[Hamza] Was ist eigentlich der Unterschied zwischen Backkakao und normalem Kakao?
Backkakao ist stark entölt. Und Trinkkakao, das ist mit Zucker zugesetzt und das ist eigentlich so ein Fertiggetränk sozusagen.
So, Vanilleextrakt..
[Hamza] Also das Natürliche ist quasi Backkakao?
[Kiki] Ja!
Also ich verrühre das jetzt. Guck mal, das war jetzt nicht schlau von mir! Daran merkt man auch, dass es spät ist!
Ich hätte erstmal verrühren sollen und dann die Butter hinzufügen sollen.
Aber ist nicht schlimm! Ich verrühre das so, dass zumindest der Backkakao sich mit der Milch verbindet
und dann lassen wir das einmal erhitzen.
[Hamza] Das kriegst du schon hin Kiki!
[Kiki] Auf jeden Fall, das ist nicht so schlimm!
Also es geht nur darum, dass es wirklich einmal erwärmt wird und dass es sich miteinander verbindet.
Nicht aufkochen sondern wirklich nur erwärmen.
Und der Kuchen ist auch schon fertig.
Und wir machen's jetzt folgendermaßen: Der Kuchen ist noch lauwarm.
Das in meinem Topf, also die "Schokosoße" sage ich mal, die ist auch lauwarm geworden.
Und jetzt nehmt ihr euch einen Schaschlikspieß und stecht einfach fröhlich rein!
[Hamza] Das erinnert mich irgendwie an Trileçe!
[Kiki] Ja, ne? Also es gibt halt 2 Möglichkeiten..
[Hamza] Trileçe kann ich auch backen. Ich weiß, wie das funktioniert! Da macht man Milch einfach rein, ne?
[Kiki] Das weiß ich!
[Kiki] Ja!
Ihr habt ja 2 Möglichkeiten: Entweder dreht ihr halt den ganzen Kuchen um weil unten sind ja die "offenen Poren" sage ich mal
oder ihr öffnet die indem ihr da reinstecht.
Das macht Spaß!
So hab ich ja grad auch die Stäbchenprobe gemacht. Also einfach reinstechen und wenn nix hängen bleibt, ist der Kuchen gar.
So, als nächstes mache ich eine richtig leckere Haselnussglasur.
Aber kurz vorab: Ihr müsst euch vorstellen das ist pure Flüssigkeit
und daher ist es ganz normal, dass hier so ein bisschen was ausläuft. Also da dürft ihr euch keine Sorgen machen!
Wichtig ist, dass 98% der Flüssigkeit wirklich vom Teig aufgesogen wird.
Jetzt gehe ich einmal rüber und habe hier Sahne in meinem Topf.
Und das werde ich jetzt erwärmen. Nicht aufkochen, es soll jetzt nicht hochsteigen!
Das ist ganz wichtig. Die erwärme ich nur, gebe dann Vollmilchkuvertüre rein - die habe ich hier schon mal gehackt. Also gleich erst, wenn das erwärmt ist!
Und dann könnt ihr auch schon die Hitze ausschalten, schön erwärmen lassen und dann gebe ich einen Esslöffel meiner Haselnusscreme rein
und anschließend noch Haselnusskerne. Und dann ist die Glasur perfekt,
kann direkt auf den Kuchen und der Kuchen ist fertig!
Also wenn ein Kuchen so aussieht, dann finde ich kann er nur schmecken!
Es ist auf jeden Fall echt ein Hingucker auch wenn der so klassisch aussieht!
Ich mag das einfach, wenn ein Kuchen nach "Ich bin lecker!" schreit.
Weil so sieht der auch einfach aus und ich wünsche euch jetzt ganz viel Spaß beim Nachmachen!
Ich werde meinen jetzt in den Kühlschrank geben und morgen genießen, ihr seht's dann bestimmt auf Instagram unseren Taste Test!
Und euch wünsche ich ganz viel Spaß beim Nachmachen.
Und hinterlasst mir gerne Feedback unter dem Video, wie euch das Rezept gefallen hat wenn ihr's ausprobiert habt
und dann würde ich mal sagen: Bis zum nächsten Mal!
Tschüss, eure Kiki!